[Music]
if you were a kid in the 90s you might
remember this show legends of the Hidden
Temple this guy was the host
Kirk Fogg thank you thank you nice to
see you legends of the Hidden Temple for
those who didn't watch it was an iconic
game show out of the 90s by Nickelodeon
are you ready Olmec let's rock
barely anybody won there were a hundred
and twenty shows and like only 30
winners teams are you ready I guess now
we can finally get answers to all of our
legends of the Hidden Temple questions
who was Olmec yeah as it turns out there
was a guy standing inside his face but
he stands back there and he has a
microphone here his copy here and he has
his hand on the lever that handles the
mouth I'm gonna ruin it for all the kids
a lot of people asked who were the
temple guards they were the guys who
used to help out during the show but
here's a little behind the scene secret
occasionally some of the writers would
dress up I think they vicariously got a
thrill out of scaring the crap out of
kids going temple I felt bad for a few
of them but they really did scare the
crap out of kids this poor girl got
really super upset in the middle of the
run and she threw up and unfortunately
she threw up in the pit of despair feels
good
everybody asked what was the hardest
room and I think probably for everybody
it was the shrine of the silver monkey
these three things look similar together
because they're kind of all silver so
you have to kind of stack them on turn
around
turn the head around I was actually an
expert at it so yeah the temple was
pretty impossible is that the only
reason there were so few winners the
producers were only allowed to give out
eight championships a year so there was
a budget and that's the truth of that
No yeah hi i'm lenny lipton this is my
dog bell lenny lipton is sitting in his
living room Puff the Magic Dragon
reading something you've probably heard
live by the sea and frolicked in the
autumn mist in a land called honah Lee
Lenny wrote what has become the stoners
anthem I wrote Puff the Magic Dragon
when he was a 19 year old college
student I was a freshman at Cornell
well can you sit thank you dear okay I
was reading a poem by Ogden Nash called
custard the dragon soon after he went to
meet friends for dinner as I was walking
down the hill this to the apartment I
was thinking about the poem I read and I
thought I'd try to write one too about a
dream he got to his friend's apartment
and let himself in I saw a typewriter on
a kitchen table I typed puff the magic
dragon lived by the sea and frolicked in
the autumn mist Michael Connelly and
although I didn't find out about this
for a couple of years peter Yarrow who
became the Peter Peter Paul Mary is one
of the guys who lived in the apartment
he saved the poem I completely forgot
about I even left it in the typewriter
and he set it to music that's how the
song I written and it changed my life
but Lenny's story doesn't stop there
I've got something like seventy two
patents I invented the way to project 3d
movies you're likely to see me go to the
cinemas he also invented those awkward
glasses you have to wear to see them
this is crystallize this is the first
commercial pair of 3d active
electronic I were and everyone from NASA
to James Cameron has used that NASA on
Mars and Cameron underwater Lenny is
also a filmmaker he's produced over 25
movies
it's a Lifetime Achievement Award and
he's written several books all about
well film and one autobiography but I
don't think it's of interest quite read
one chapter and she said she did want to
read any more okay so a book about his
life is not his magnum opus good thing a
song about drugs is cuz that's what it's
about right people want to think it's
about pot that's fine with me
wait it's not not as far as I'm
concerned Puff the Magic Dragon is not
about drugs and who knows who knows what
I was thinking
in 1992 Nickelodeon debuted the TV show
guts
it was just like American Gladiator only
the contestants were all kids and while
the show was epic in every way the theme
song is one of those pieces where you
start singing it and somebody next to
you joins in so we found the guy who
wrote it my name is Rick McCallum IM the
composer of the nickelodeon theme song
guts do you have it do you have it it's
dedication I got the call to do this
piece hip hop was just coming to age
immediately it came to mind do you have
it yes they liked it and they said you
think you can put a little rap to it yes
sure
I'm a polish guy from West Virginia like
I can rap yeah it takes a certain kind
of something to keep the heart pumping
something everybody needs to achieve to
succeed you'll need a lot they were big
on the sound effects stuff in that to it
you can hear me in there I sample my
myself so Rick he didn't just write the
theme song for guts he was kind of the
90s jingle guy for Nickelodeon Guk's was
my first yeah first show for Nickelodeon
I did some music for the big help
they're all music for Kids Choice Awards
figure it out a remake of family double
dare I did stuff for Nick at night also
Nick at Nite oh here's a show I forgot
to mention I did the music for a show
called actually now action be now
starring the flesh my buck for this how
I love to be involved in having a hit
record you know I'm still working on
that but I guess you know to a degree
like the guts team it's my hit so I'm
pretty happy about that
[Music]
there's this amazing picture of my
coworker
it's him reading a Ninja Turtles book
lying next to a super soaker when the
super soaker came out it was a game
changer the slogan wetter is better was
essentially a mantra for kids during
summer break so when I went to Atlanta
to interview the guy responsible for all
that I had to show him the photo that's
Lenny Lonnie Johnson invented the super
soaker back in 1982 but that is not his
only invention well I have over 100
patents everything from the nerf gun to
a thermoelectric energy converter he
also worked on NASA's Galileo mission to
Jupiter and alongside the US military
the first Super Soaker actually I made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when I would come home from
work and at the time I was actually
working with a stealth bomber program
back when it was highly classified and I
actually couldn't even tell my wife but
I was working on during the daytime it
was that that top-secret the original
name for the Super Soaker was the drench
err we ran into a challenge regarding
the name because another
and been acclaimed until we changed the
name to Super Soaker just to avoid
having to deal with that Super Soaker is
definitely a way better name when he
started Loni wasn't trying to create a
toy for kids I was working on a new type
of heat pump that would use water as a
working fluid instead of freon and I was
experimenting with sig nozzles that I
had machine and I shot a stream of water
across the bathroom and that pouches
maybe I should put this hard science
stuff aside and work on something fun
like a water gun this deal worked and
this brings me back to a previous point
Lonnie Johnson is a super genius
scientist this is his lab and this is
what he's working on now yeah right now
I'm working on advanced matric
technology my goal is to develop a
battery that will store about 3 times
the energy of a lithium ion battery in
comparison the Super Soaker might not
seem as hard science but it was still a
really really important invention
it's been well when way on supermarkets
we supermarket sweep was an iconic game
show in the 90s and early 2000 and here
is our host David Brent thank you but
what most people didn't know all the
meat was fake and all the other food had
gone bad are you ready to play the game
welcome to supermarket sweep go big shot
for about five months six months every
year and they used the same food over
and over again so by about the third
month the hotdogs had sort of started to
ferment in the package and package
swelled up and and a lot of the food
having been thrown in and out of carts
for three four months had gotten pretty
beaten up and one of the things people
always ask me is do they get to keep the
food and no and if they didn't win
because there were three teams they got
their sweatshirts
unfortunately the winning team did not
get their sweatshirts interestingly
enough they've got $5,000 but they
didn't get their sweatshirts
I shouldn't be telling you this this
trade secret very few people know this
and very few people use this strategy
but those who did one instead of five
hams and five turkeys that load up your
cart you come over here and you get five
of these hair colorings and then you get
well we won't we won't mess with maxi
pads you get five of all these expensive
health and beauty products with one cart
you can beat everybody
don't tell anybody just you and me what
a fantasy be able to run around grab
your favorite foods as much of it as you
want and not have to pay for it this is
David Ruprecht saying next time you're
to checkout stand and you hear the beep
think of all the fun you could have on
[Music]
[Music]